there are so many benefits to doing
intermittent fasting but there's also
the dark side which I want to talk about
too the benefits are weight loss
cognitive improvements Focus attention
memory or heart issue or whatever you're
going to find those will probably be a
lot better but here's a thing you need
to know about intermittent fasting okay
your avoiding food for a period of time
and most of the things I'm going to talk
about are not related necessarily to a
16 or 17 or 18 hour fast I'm talking
about when you do prolonged fasting
let's say you're doing it for 48 hours
72 or even longer this information
applies more to that situation all right
so here's the thing the purpose of food
is to not just get fuel for your body
is to get nutrients from the food so if
you are not eating because you're
fasting okay you're restricting
nutrients and if your diet is not
providing all the nutrients okay you can
end up with not just deficiencies but
what's called subclinical nutrition
deficiencies and that can set you up for
a lot of problems so virtually all the
things I'm going to talk about are
related to that one point so let's first
talk about the first one it's called
refeeding syndrome so let's say you do
this uh I don't know three or four or
five day fast okay and then you eat this
huge meal not a good idea especially if
you eat a carbohydrate meal and you have
some type of pre-existing nutritional
deficiency because this could be
dangerous and you can have a lot of
problems it's always good and safe when
you come off a fast to just have a
little bit of food wait for a couple
hours eat a little bit more and I
wouldn't do carbohydrates I would do a
little protein maybe an egg or a little
bit salad wait a little bit maybe have
some nuts an avocado things like that
but don't do what I did I mean I was
just like because I didn't eat for a
long period of time I over compensated I
just ate a ton of food and I felt really
good for about a minute and then I'm
like oh my gosh I don't feel too good I
feel really sick my body from not eating
just wasn't used to that much food so
break your fast with a smaller meal and
gradually come out of it I will put a
link down below for more details on that
thing but this refeeding syndrome
problem usually occurs if you know maybe
you have a problem with anorexia or
you're a chronic alcoholic or you have
some type of malabsorption issue where
you don't get enough nutrition because
you have inflammatory issues in your gut
or your elderly or you have advanced
diabetes or even you're on certain
medications like antacids or diuretics
that deplete you of certain nutrients or
you just basically have a low vitamin B1
deficiency so that's when you start
having problems with the refeeding
syndrome because we have this shift of
fluid and electrolytes from inside the
cell
to the blood all right so that's number
one number two dirty keto which is
basically you're doing low carb but
you're not looking at the quality of the
food you're not looking at nutrients and
like I said before it's always this
nutritional deficiency problem because
when you eat junk food even if it's low
carb junk food the quality is not there
the nutrition is not there it can set
you up for more problems because you're
not eating and you're restricting these
nutrients even more like for example
zinc your body has enough stored zinc to
last like four days well let's say you
don't get enough zinc from the diet
which a lot of people don't and then
here you are going into this fastest
situation and then you just magnified
that deficiency in a zinc deficiency can
show up as a weakness within your immune
system it can affect your taste it can
affect your vision it can affect your
skin it can affect your stomach like
gastritis things like that all right
number three not taking nutrients while
you're fasting I always recommend taking
at at least at a bare minimum
electrolytes trace minerals and B
vitamins but the point is if you don't
take these electrolytes and I'm also
talking about sea salt and you're
fasting especially two three or four or
five days you might have issues like
feeling faint dizzy heard about people
just passed out and also when you're
either on the ketogenic diet or you do
intermittent fasting you're running on
ketones running on ketones increases the
demand for certain nutrients like
vitamin B1 and other B vitamins and even
potassium which means you can also end
up with something like keto fatigue or a
keto rash or just weakness in general
all right number four kidney stones
kidney stones can occur for several
reasons the most common one is uric acid
stones and let's say for example you're
doing in the ketogenic diet you're doing
intermittent fasting typically people
eat a lot of almonds right and they
might do some non-sugar chocolate or
they also might do spinach all three of
those are very high in oxalates and if
you're predisposed to kidney stones
that could make it worse I would
definitely avoid those Foods if you have
a tendency to get kidney stones and I
would also take lemon juice in your
water
and drink enough water like two and a
half liters of fluid a day and that
alone should prevent kidney stones now
the other type of kidney stones is uric
acid Stones it is true when you do long
fast your uric acid goes up okay and
then it comes down and stabilizes
that's not a pathogenic problem because
uric acid is probably one of the most
potent antioxidants in your blood and so
it doesn't mean that you're going to
have gout or some type of arthritis no
it just means when you do a fast you may
have certain chemistry changes occurring
and one really good thing for uric acid
just to kind of counter it when you
eventually eat make sure you have big
salads which I always recommend
to kind of flesh out any type of uric
acid that might be concentrating now
this may become a problem if with a
person doing
uh carnivore but I have not really seen
that being a problem somehow the body
compensates and they don't seem to have
more problems with gout they have less
problems with gout even though they're
doing a lot of animal protein which is
interesting number five if you're
anorexic you're going to have
nutritional deficiencies so when you do
intermittent fasting it's going to
create more of a problem so I don't
recommend intermittent fasting if you're
bulimic or anorexic but I do recommend
the ketogenic diet for sure but not
prolong fasting number six athletes that
have not adapted to Fat yet okay so in
this process of getting on keto you
start adapting to keto which within like
three days but then it actually takes
one to three months to fully adapt to
your fat metabolism right so to be fat
adapted it takes a lot longer than what
you might think so in the process and
you're working out you may not have
adapted to Fat so when you exercise you
might kind of have energy and then kind
of come down but I will say over time
there are athletes that have adapted to
this fat
over a period of months and man they can
burn fat three times better than anyone
else they can just go go so the point is
that you have to give it more time and
in the process of this adaptation you
might want to adjust your workouts and
training maybe right after you eat until
you can fully fat adapt just as a side
note too if you're an athlete and you're
exercising and you don't have enough a
sea salt your muscles will be weak okay
also potassium is very very important as
well number seven if you're a child okay
not the best idea to do any type of
prolonged fasting now let's say you're a
teenager overweight like let's say
you're obese well maybe you would just
do like two meals but I would definitely
start cutting out the snacking I don't
agree with this snacking all day long
but the point is if you have three solid
meals with a child and they're nutrient
dense I mean that's what you want to do
why because what we're trying to do is
prevent and nutritional deficiencies and
it is more difficult to get nutrients
from food nowadays I mean even go in the
grocery store most of the lettuces that
you eat are Hydroponic and I do have a
problem with that because they only put
15 minerals in there and they're kind of
bland they tasteless I really don't
think they have the same nutrients as
salad that's grown on soil all right
number eight nutrition is most important
when you're pregnant and when you're
lactating because you're eating for two
and you're providing milk and your body
is becoming depleted just a deficiency
of vitamin D can set your child up for
all sorts of dental malformations which
then cause the need for braces down the
road or they might have an overbite or
an underbite or they might have flat
feet or bowed legs all of these things
can be easily solved if that mother has
enough of the right nutrients also
realize that most the prenatals out
there are all synthetic get a whole food
natural prenatal especially take it when
you're breastfeeding as well and one
more point about infant formulas and
baby food unfortunately
it's like Ultra processed food if you
look at the ingredients
it doesn't even resemble real food
unfortunately so there are some
Alternatives I will put a link down
below of what I recommend for
um for children like baby food that's
actually much better number nine if you
have a loss of muscle let's say for
example you're older and you're starting
to develop muscle loss and you're doing
intermittent fasting
I recommend adding one additional
nutrient a blend of amino acids that can
actually give you this raw material
without creating a problem of it turning
into sugar but it can actually Supply
the muscles to prevent a loss of muscle
and if you're taking the other nutrients
like the B vitamins and electrolytes you
allow these amino acids to be formed as
muscle because all the biochemistry all
the requirements for the enzymes mostly
they're just protein and this goes
beyond the Protein that's needed for
muscle ligament tendon fascia connective
tissue all of those protein molecules
need cofactors and coenzymes and those
are the vitamins and minerals so we come
full circle to these nutrients right so
I'm trying to really emphasize that one
point and then number 10
ketoacidosis if you look up the dangers
of fasting if you look up the the
dangers of Keto you will see this word
keeps coming up this is a situation
where you have too much ketones going in
your body and too many ketones are
producing an acidity in your blood which
can be very very dangerous okay but
there's so much confusion I want to just
clarify this right now you have
physiological ketosis okay and you also
have
ketoacidosis they're not the same at all
the point is that ketoacidosis is very
rare unless you have the following
conditions uncontrolled diabetes where
you have type 1 diabetes sometimes type
2 you're taking insulin and you forgot
to take your insulin in type 1 you have
the cells of the pancreas that have just
basically stopped producing insulin okay
so what's going to happen to your blood
sugars they're going to go very very
high because you have no insulin to
monitor that or or regulate that but
insulin also controls ketones and so
insulin suppresses ketones and if you
have no more insulin you have this
massive flush or generation of ketones
so your body starts burning fat like
crazy and you have very high levels
above 10 or 11 or 12 levels of ketones
now typically when you do the
physiological ketones which you're this
is a natural process you restrict
carbohydrates and usually you're going
to go between 0.5 to 3. I haven't seen
many people go over five or even six and
to do that you have to do prolonged
fasting and exercise but the great
majority of people are going to be three
I mean this is a very far range from 10
okay so uncontrolled diabetes
if you're a chronic alcoholic okay you
could have the same problem if you're on
certain medications like high levels of
aspirin can create this situation even
certain drugs like cocaine for example
you can go into this ketoacidosis when
you abuse cocaine or there's other
conditions like chronic liver disease
right where the liver is very very
damaged and on top of that you're a
diabetic that can create a problem as
well or even if you're um pregnant
malnutrition so as you can see there are
conditions that can make you more
vulnerable to this ketoacidosis but it's
very very rare the physiologic ketosis
okay is not pathogenic it's extremely
healthy and there's huge benefits if
anyone says that ketosis is is toxic
just ask them about what about
glucotoxicity right that's high carb
that's high sugar what is that that's
like all the bad effects from diabetes
because you're massively high sugar what
about the dangers of that and also think
about this one last Point keep acidosis
usually originates because you're eating
too many carbs you're not doing low carb
you're eating high carbs destroys the
pancreas and then you get ketoacidosis
so anyway I just wanted to cover these
points the next point is if you now want
to know how to do intermittent fasting
correctly you should watch this video
right here